all right joining us now with the
reaction to our our explosive interview
with the son of one of the founders of
Hamas uh plus the latest on the war in
Israel former Secretary of State Fox
News contributor let's give a warm
welcome Mike Pompeo is with us sir how
are
you I'm good Sean how are you this
evening I'm good it's amazing I don't
know if you saw Sarah's report and you
heard this the son of Hamas but this is
something we have known all all the
years we've been covering this all the
years you a CIA director congressman and
Secretary of State how is it possible
there such a high level of ignorance on
this
issue Sean it's truly remarkable and to
listen I did get to hear both of those
reports to listen to this son of the
leader of Hamas uh understand the
situation better than our president
right our president wants to ask the
Israelis to stop and to pause and think
that they can negotiate or that the
Palestinian Authority can control what's
going on in Gaza this guy understood
like you have to annihilate Hamas they
they have to be eliminated there's no
there's no well gosh can't we all just
get along he he truly I I heard
President Obama I think it was yesterday
day before said that we're all complicit
that's just false the the truth is is
that the the failure of America to
defend and deter to stand with our
partner uh the Jewish people in Israel
uh their in their rightful homeland of
now 3,000 years to not be with them and
to to be demanding that they conduct a
ceasefire while Hamas is still roaming
the Earth after killing
1,400 citizens in a barbaric attack
including many Americans and while the
Iranians are firing rockets at American
servicemen and women throughout the
Middle East uh President Biden has got
to stand up and defend America we have
to restore deterrence we can and to hear
this son of Hamas understand that
frankly in a way that he articulated in
a way that President Biden has not it's
it's both sad and dangerous so you have
Hamas in the South you have his in the
north now you have the hooti rebels have
joined in you got Rockets being fired
from Syria and then we've got this
little country called Aran uh that has
been the number one state sponsor of
Terror for a long time you were involved
in the taking out of of their lead
General
solomani at what point does the world
have to recognize and unite around the
fact that Iran can no longer get away
with proxy wars and fomenting Terror
like this
boy I we're well past that time I hope
October 7th was a wake up for some who
just weren't where we were in the Trump
Administration we knew that if you
isolated Iran you could create peace and
prosperity in the region we did that
with the Abraham Accords Iran was down
to just about its last nickel less than
$4 billion and today it's got over $70
billion and you know even today Sean
they probably sold 3 million barrels of
crude oil on the open market as they're
holding Americans hostage inside of Gaza
I hope I hope the whole world can see
that this is a mission that is important
this this won't just stay in Israel this
won't just stay in the Middle East this
will threaten the entire world and we
have the capacity to stand up to Iran
hold them accountable impose real costs
on them and when we do we'll create
Better Lives for all of the people in
the entire region the Palestinians
living in Gaza the Gulfs the those who
are living in the Gulf Arab states and
our friend and Ally the people of Israel
as well can you please explain to
President Joe Biden why it is a bad idea
to ask our top Ally in the region to put
a pause in the fighting apparently the
pressure is becoming enormous what do
you say to Joe
Biden uh President Biden please
understand that is an enormous mistake
you should be demanding demanding that
Hamas release the hostages with all of
your energy and with all of your might I
hope prime minister Netanyahu and the
Israeli
leadership I hope they'll do the
necessary even in the face of American
resistance uh we we should let the
Israelis do what needs to be done
they're quite capable of doing it they
need our support to push back to make
sure that Hezbollah and the others don't
get involved but if we continue to try
and restrain Israel we will only
embolden these very barbarians who took
so much life on October 7th Sean former
Secretary of State former CIA director
Mike Pompeo thank you as always we
appreciate you being here hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else